It was only a matter of time before Chris
Pratt became an A-list movie star.
He's now at the center of multiple franchises
— he's Star-Lord in Guardians of the Galaxy,
Owen in Jurassic World, and Emmett in The
Lego Movie.
But Pratt slowly built up his career with
regular roles on TV and supporting roles in
big-screen productions before earning his
spot on the top.
Throughout it all, Pratt has proven to be
a charming, entertaining, and most of all,
hilarious guy.
Here are some times that the camera captured
him on movie and TV sets goofing off, screwing
up, and ad-libbing.
The O.C.
One of Pratt's earliest roles was playing
Ché on Fox's teen soap The O.C..
And while the part mostly required him to
act like a burnout, he did seem to have a
lot of fun with it … until he had to eat
on-camera, that is.
In one scene, he was supposed to be giving
sage advice to Seth Cohen while eating a bowl
of figs.
And it probably would've gone off without
a hitch if Pratt hadn't grabbed a spoiled
piece of fruit.
"I'm sorry.
This one's a bad one."
What's Your Number?
Wearing a fat suit might hinder some actors'
ability to bust a move, but that wasn't the
case for Chris Pratt.
In What's Your Number?, Pratt had to bulk
up a bit, but he still managed to bust out
some impressively accurate Michael Jackson
dance moves that were totally uninhibited
by the extra poundage.
He should put that on his resume.
Parks and Recreation
Pratt didn't come out of nowhere to become
the biggest action hero working today.
Before he started saving the world, he was
best known for his supporting role in NBC
comedy Parks and Recreation.
But the inklings of a hero were still present
in his role as the dumb but eager man-child
Andy Dwyer.
In this outtake, Pratt rapidly hurdled over
a counter and then ditched a briefcase his
character didn't need to steal by throwing
it back from where he got it.
Amazingly, the case nailed a light switch
— and left the actors in the dark.
"F------ hilarious."
"That's not something that props can fix.
Sorry.
I'm out."
Delivery Man
Even though Chris Pratt was on the cusp of
mega success when he starred in this 2013
comedy, he was still pretty hungry.
At least, that's all we can assume from watching
this outtake of him chasing a wad of cash
from blowing away in the wind.
"Why not is that too real?
Is that too real?"
Jurassic World
Pratt's character, Owen, can do a lot of things.
He can ride a motorcycle, he can tame velociraptors,
and he can even make the T-Rex look like a
good guy.
But acting out one of Owen's talents in particular
gave Chris Pratt some trouble on the set.
While his character was capable of doing crazy
things, Pratt had a lot of trouble whistling
— and the behind-the-scenes footage of his
repeated failed efforts made for some great
B-roll.
"I'll get it."
Guardians of the Galaxy
Flying a spaceship is fun, and it would seem
that even pretending to fly a spaceship is
also a thrill, because on the set of Guardians
of the Galaxy, Pratt got a little carried
away behind the controls of the mighty Milano.
The filmmakers probably only really needed
a second or two of Star-Lord looking excited,
but Pratt got downright maniacal with his
unbridled glee.
"Hahaha!"
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2
The Guardians returned for some more outer
space adventures in Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 2, but they weren't alone.
A few new characters came along, including
an ageless Celestial named Ego, who was also
Star-Lord's father, played by Kurt Russell.
Because the movie was set on several distant
planets, gravity wasn't always a given.
So to replicate that, the actors had to endure
a lot of "wire work."
And in this outtake from the movie, Pratt
and Russell had a hard time getting the "hang"
of things.
"I think we got it."
The film also presented another all-star blooper
when we were introduced to the High Priestess
of the Sovereigns.
She tried to chat up the Star-Lord about breeding
techniques, and she got this as an explanation
of how earthlings do it:
"I personally control half the DNA by doing
something I call doinking."
Passengers
For a large portion his other space movie
Passengers, Chris Pratt wandered around a
gigantic ship almost entirely by himself.
His only "human" interaction was with an android
bartender named Arthur, played by Michael
Sheen.
Arthur provided drinks and a little bit of
companionship…and since there wasn't much
else to do, Pratt's character was a patron
of the pub quite often.
In this outtake, Pratt got a chance to do
some "drunk acting," and he comically over-reacted
to Arthur's boozy blue concoction...
"There's coconut in it?"
It's amazing none of these moments made into
the movies, really.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!